hey guys welcome back to a brand-new
[ __ ] video that's really loud sorry
but I read in the patch notes yesterday
that as you can see by the title
gladiator got a buff as if he couldn't
get any better than he already is now
there was a few minor changes but there
are some big changes first up being the
sucker punch simple move like that there
was a bug where it didn't drain stamina
when hitting the opponent so that should
be fixed now so simple stuff like that
but there's also the crowd-pleaser
which is the dashing light and the bee
sting which is the side bash light those
before use the half a thousand
millisecond recovery
meaning if you were to block said move
it would be a free guard break against
me and I couldn't guard break it but now
they reduced the recovery so that it's
800 milliseconds so now I can do this
without repercussions and can't get
guard broken I can now Connor guard
break right back which makes it in line
with the characters like Valkyrie as
well which is super cool so as always
we're gonna be testing out this new buff
and all that stuff and some duels so
let's get started and the first enemy we
have to fight today is a rep 10 warden
kind of expected a lot of wardens to be
coming here since he on the new rubrics
and stuff like that so see how we can do
see what he's thinking stuff like that
you'll fight my boy
[Music]
damn I thought I'd block that I'm pretty
sure my cursor was on him asada done a
good zone okay all right
good start just trying to feel for what
this guy's got what he's got going on
his move style stuff like that just
trying to catch it
Oh starts off with a - heavy yeah
there's that buff in play perfect I
seems to know the the the animation of
where it's coming so imma have to like
chill out for a bit on that move at
least with the follow up afterwards I
student and this guy's really backing up
he he's just only throwing that move out
it's odd
right
well come back didn't there was a few
things I didn't want to do at that point
oh good stuff I was trying to bait out
the I was trying to bait out his bait
because obviously he did the zone a
heavy cancel trying to fish for a parry
there and I tried I fainted with the
sole intent that he would throw
something and then that didn't not clay
didn't work is he throw light stuff
that's a [ __ ] start knives it okay got a
few you know a few decent damage it's
not bad
ah okay okay still trying to get a feel
from though I got the car break I had a
feeling who's gonna let that rip for
some reason
alright caught him on that good stuff
dude
I'm catching him I'm catching them on
these hits is good stuff
oh good catch
Oh while he whipped that real long
all right so rolling out of that dodges
that zone he's gonna keep doing that to
me
I can't I think I'm one hit away with
the zone I'm not too sure though I don't
remember how I'm gonna show and damage
he does
either way ever not we're not gonna make
it we're gonna make sure he doesn't find
out I think I'm definitely one hit
though cuz that was some chip damage I
don't like that I were lower in him he's
within one-hit kill zone range ah the
[ __ ] - heavy that's 500 milliseconds
it's pretty it's a pretty fast attack
it's kind of shitty because it's fast
and it only gives a heavy parry off it
which I don't really like too much
[Music]
I need to start getting a parry I just
can't I can't I can't catch his lights
sometimes like it's not that like I know
I know
I'll cover god I thought I [ __ ] that
up a bit the the heavy input didn't stay
all right I just I can't guess his
lights sometimes like two and I can
block them occasionally but like pairing
is just sometimes non-existent for fast
moves like that ah [ __ ] you through the
baton to me again damn good fight did I
keep trying to throw the bait in so that
he catches it and but he always falls up
without light and he gets him every time
good fight man and for the last game cuz
I'm probably only gonna be doing two for
this and who would have thought another
[ __ ] warden they're mine and for the
final match today we have the other rep
20 warden like I just said and for the
last match we're gonna be fighting a rep
25 konk not big on conquer I think that
he got a little bit over buffed in his
rear or a couple seasons ago but we'll
see how this continues to play off not
really that great against conks really I
mean obviously he just got the rework
problem not really that great against
warden either slowly chipping away at
his health right now I probably should
be getting these parries but I'm just
too nervous to just throw [ __ ] at the
moment
and with that spicy zone I could stuffed
it a little bit difficult I think I can
get used to I'm getting used to it a
little bit with this fight
I might start pairing a little bit more
hopefully I haven't seen him do heavy
cancels and to shield bash because once
that happens is basically gg for me
we'll see how this flight goes will
continue on I meant to do a toe stab not
that yeah it didn't want to go to
stamina but I'd rather take the
confirmed damage at the moment damn it
moves so safe can't really do much off
that all right you chipped me away I was
being a little stupid
I'll admit I'll take the little trade
though quick 10 toe stab damage for the
13 light on him good stuff I don't know
I know I might be getting a little bit
better at [ __ ] maybe maybe not
good just be me let me know if you guys
want to see some rank 2 gameplay or
anything of that a glad I just played a
few ranked games and Louie lost all
three of them because they were all
roaches and Orochi on console you play
console you know my pain man Orochi
Roshan consoles and already confirmed
win it's pretty dumb so I don't know if
you guys want me to do some gladiator
ranked gameplay I'll gladly do it it's
probably gonna be some gold platinum
type [ __ ] I'm never making it's a
[ __ ] Grand Master whatever the hell
that rank is not not ever in my life
ah that [ __ ] full block did such a
shitty move here kill though I hate that
[ __ ] move it's it's just so much
damage on one confirmed but like on one
button input' so whack he's melting me
now damn he clapped me on that round I
don't know what I was doing dude I'm
just [ __ ] I'm getting destroyed I was
doing so well in the beginning I need to
buckle down and like focus a bit more I
just started throwing out random attacks
that I shouldn't have been doing
I'll go Barry
throwing out random moves interesting
I'll get another pair
I was just randomly throwing out the
heavy to see if I could do something
after that I should have been a [ __ ]
that should have been a heavy but I'll
take the stamina damage from it you mean
ever they didn't do much
I forgot that that's a [ __ ] I forgot
that that's a light now I'm not giving
him the benefit of the doubt for that
one
[Music]
no you do that was so close ah [ __ ] I
[ __ ] up yeah guys it's going to be the
end of the videotape because I got
unlucky today I have fought the conch
but then made some stupid mistakes ended
up losing pretty much the whole game
which sucks and then with the warden
since it's the new warden rework I I
didn't really know how to fight him so
we got unlucky today we couldn't really
get a win but maybe we'll catch some and
a few other days or something like that
I just have to learn how to improve from
that and hopefully learn how to fight
these reworks in the next couple days
since of course they are just recently
new but yeah as always guys like the V
if you do enjoy subscribe for new I
covered the informational site a
foreigner that being balance changes
hero updates patch notes all that good
stuff as well as some gladiator gameplay
my two most elusive videos will be on
screen if you guys want to check that
out with that guys so be a great
yesterday they crossed in the video
peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]